ALL RIGHT, HERE'S WHAT WE DID
YESTERDAY. THE FIRST FOUR
ROUNDS OF THE ALL-TIME IN THE
PRIME DRAFT CHRIS
UP AROUND 5:00. LET'S GET
THROUGH AS MANY AS WE CAN WHO
YOU GOT. ALL RIGHT. WELL, I
GUESS I NEEDED SOME POINT
THEY PASS PROTECTOR HERE SO
I'M GOING TO GO WITH JONATHAN
OGDEN. ALL RIGHT, LEFT TACKLE
BALTIMORE RAVENS NEED SOMEBODY
TO PROTECT PATRICK MY HOME SO
HE CAN DANCE BACK THERE AND
MAKE ALL THESE PLAYS. I'LL GO
WITH HIM.
ALL RIGHT, I'M GOING WITH
RANDY MOSS, AND I'M
TALL. I'M TELLING YOU, IF YOU
HADN'T TAKEN
JERRY RICE BECAUSE I WAS
AFRAID YOU GOING TO TAKE MOSS
NECK, I WAS, I WAS GOING TO
RISE HOWARD TAKING MOSS ANYWAY
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH RICE IS
MORE COMPLEX AND I THINK
BETTER BECAUSE HE GOT THE MOST
OUT OF HIS TALENTS
AND THEY'LL TAKE MY CHANCES
WITH A GUY WHO'S GOT MORE
TALENT IN HIS PRIME AND IT'S
RANDY MOSS. YEAH. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. YEAH, YOU KNOW
WHAT I SHOULD HAVE TOOK
MOM? I DON'T EVEN NEED PRIME.
RANDY MOSS. I'LL TAKE 98.
RANDY MOSS. I'LL TAKE
RECALLED AND THAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN
PRAYIN. ANYWAYS,
GUSTY ACT,
YES.
IS THAT A DISGUSTING ACT?
YOU KNOW?
OKAY, THAT'S YOUR FULL OF
RECEIVER. THAT WAS A GREAT
GAME THAT WAS HIS LAST WIN
WITH THE VIKINGS 2004.
PLAYOFFS, GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT.
ALRIGHT, I'M GOING TO GO BACK
TO DEFENSE HERE, I'M GONNA GET
RAY LEWIS IN THE MIDDLE OF MY
DEFENSE FIRST OFF, BUT HE'S
PLAYING MIDDLE LINEBACKER FOR
ME. MAN TO BALTIMORE
GUYS, BACK TO BACK AND THEY
WERE ON THE SAME TEAM AT ONE
POINT,
BUT YEAH. DRAFTED THE SAME
YEAR IN THE SAME ROUND, RAISE
A YOU KNOW COME ON THE BEST
MIDDLE LINEBACKER EVER PERIOD.
THAT'S ALL THERE IS TO SAY
ABOUT THAT. SO I'M TAKING HIM
HIM THERE.
I'M GOING DEACON JONES
NEXT. WHOA.
ESPECIALLY IF
IF I CAN
BRING HIM IN HIS PRIME
WITH THE ABILITY TO PERFORM
THE HEAD SLAP BUT EVEN WITHOUT
THE HEAD SLAB, DEACON JONES
UNAPPRECIATED BECAUSE STATS
WEREN'T OR SACKS, WEREN'T A
STAT, OR STATS WERE IN A SACK
BACK THEN
I THINK DEACON JONES
EVERY BIT AS POTENT AS REGGIE
WHITE. AND I'M A LITTLE
SURPRISED FOOTBALL, HIS STORY
AND YOU DIDN'T TAKE HIM.
ALTHOUGH I KNOW I FEEL
ALYSSA, THAT'S WHERE I FEEL
BAD, SOME OF THESE
OLD-SCHOOL, GUYS ARE WORTHY OF
BEING PICKED HERE AND I, YOU
KNOW, OF COURSE, WASN'T I KNOW
OF THEM. I KNOW HOW AWESOME
THEY WERE. I'VE
I'VE WATCHED A LOT OF
NFL FILMS VIDEOS, BUT YEAH,
THEY'RE NOT AS PREVALENT IN MY
BRAIN AS SOME OF THESE OTHER
GUYS THAT, YOU KNOW, WERE
PLAYING WHEN IN MY LIFETIME.
ALL RIGHT? THAT'S A GOOD ONE
THERE. YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO ROT
WIDE RECEIVER.
HERE I AM. I'M GOING TO SAY, I
GOT MY HOME'S. I NEED ANOTHER
THREAT DOWN THE FIELD. I'M
GONNA GO WITH ANOTHER TEAM.
I'M ON TERRELL OWENS. YOU TOOK
MOSS. I'M TAKING
T OWN X THAT'S GOING TO BE MY
GUY.
YOU KNOW
II DON'T I DON'T HATE THAT
AND I NEED ANOTHER OFFENSIVE
WEAPON AS WELL. I'VE GOT BARRY
SANDERS AND WE GOT RANDY MOSS.
I'VE GOT TO AUGMENT HIM
THEM WITH SOMEONE
IN HIS PRIME
GALE SAYERS.
OH YEAH I'LL SAY
ARKANSAS, COMMENT, LINE
AND LINE THEM UP IN THE SLOT.
DIDN'T HAVE SLOT RECEIVERS
BACK IN THAT DAY. PUT
GAYLE, SAYERS IN THE SLOT PUT
GAYLE SAYERS IN THE BACKFIELD
PUT GAYLE SAYERS ANYWHERE.
GIVE ME GALE SAYERS.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. I WANT
TO DO NOT REACH. ALL RIGHT,
GOSH, WHAT
DO I WANT TO DO HERE?
I'LL GO AARON, DONALD HERE,
GOING TO MAKE REGGIE,
WHITE LT, AARON DONALD. I
MEAN, JEEZ, YOUR QUARTERBACKS
HAD BRAIDS, HE'S DEAD.
THIS IS WHAT I MEAN, WE CAN'T
PLAY
ANY WARRANTS AT WARREN. SETH'S
GONNA TEXT, I FORGOT ABOUT
AARON, DONNA, WE TALKED ABOUT
HIM YESTERDAY. I THOUGHT WE
ACTUALLY TAKEN HIM.
BOY.
HMM, I GO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS
HERE. GIVE ME RONNIE
LOTTO, DON'T HAVE A SAFETY.
YEAH, THE SAFETY. I GOT A GUY
THAT CORNER. I DON'T HAVE A
SAFETY RONNIE. LOTT. I KIND OF
LIKE THIS. I WISH WE COULD
CONTINUE TO DO THIS REALLY
BECAUSE I THINK MY NECK I WANT
TO GO
GRONK NEXT.
TAKE GRONK A TIGHT END. THAT
WOULD BE MY NEXT PICK, I
THINK. WOW, YEAH, WOW.
HEY, I WANT A GOOD TIGHT END,
HE CAN RUN BLOCK
LITTLE BIT AND YOU KNOW OF
COURSE BE A
BIG-TIME THREAT IN THE PASS
PASS GAME.
I WAS CLOSING IN ON TAKING
ANOTHER QUARTERBACK BECAUSE
I'M IN HINDSIGHT, MAYBE I
SHOULD HAVE TAKEN JOHNNY
UNITAS, BUT I WAS LIKE, WHAT?
TOM BRADY BE BACK WITH MORE.